[MUSIC PLAYING]
RACHEL: Please give Bret
and Jason a heartfelt
welcome to Google Chicago.
[APPLAUSE]
BRET GORNIK: Thanks, Rachel.
Thanks everybody for
taking some time out
of your day to be here.
We're super happy to be here.
We're really excited to shed our
viewpoint, our light on having
the best day every day.
My name is Bret.
I'm the co-founder
of Live Better.
JASON LOEBIG: My
name's Jason Loebig.
I'm the other co-founder.
BRET GORNIK: We're super
excited to be here today
to be talking about
how we live the best
day ever, every day, even
when you knock over your water
bottle.
We're going to
start with a quote.
"Normal is getting dressed in
clothes that you buy for work
and driving through
traffic in a car
that you're still paying for
in order to get to the job
you need to pay for
the clothes and the car
and the house you
leave vacant all day,
so you can afford
to live in it."
We didn't like
normal, so we decided
to do this for a living.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
JASON LOEBIG: So
four years ago, I
had a really hard time
waking up for work.
I've not always been
a morning person,
although I might consider
myself to be now.
I was a public accountant,
like Rachel mentioned.
But I knew that that
was not what I really
wanted to be doing.
I wasn't waking up,
coming into the office,
rushing to get to
somewhere I wanted to be,
and I knew that there was
a little bit of passion
and purpose in teaching
people about wellness.
I love the people I worked with,
but that tangible impact that I
wanted to be making
at my place of work
was really just not there.
And that led me towards Live
Better to reconnect with Bret,
and then have that be a
normal Tuesday afternoon.
BRET GORNIK: Four years ago, I
had an hour and a half commute
to a data analytics job
that I found zero value in.
I loved everything I was
doing outside of work
and enjoyed all the activities
when I was not in the office.
Once I devoted my
life to my purpose,
I have had the best day
ever, every single day,
even on a Tuesday.
So we'll give a little intro
about how Live Better started.
Jason and I met in college
through Jason's wife,
when he would come to visit
the University of Illinois.
We were drinking buddies.
Drinking is an understatement.
We were a little
bit more than that.
We enjoyed ourselves.
We had a good time.
And we met up again a
little bit after college,
after a few years off.
I was working at Kohl's
Corporate at the time,
and then ended up transitioning
to Walgreens Corporate.
When I came back to Chicago,
I saw Jason out at a bar,
and if any of you know Jason,
he's a nice, bubbly, fun,
charismatic guy.
He looked like shit.
And I said, hey,
what's going on?
Why aren't you happy?
What's up?
And he told me that, hey, man,
I'm working a 95-hour week,
and I have to go
into work tomorrow.
Tomorrow was a Sunday.
I said, hey, man, I'm
thinking of an idea.
Let's go sit down
next week and chat.
So we sat down a
week later, what
we thought would
be for a dinner,
and has been our journey.
For the last four years,
we've met every single day.
We have started
training clients,
like I did today at
5:00 in the morning,
ended up working
throughout the entire day
at our corporate
jobs, would sneak on
to Instant Messenger chat or
run away at lunch to meet.
We'd train clients
in the evening.
We'd meet until we would
have to fall asleep.
Wake up again in the morning.
We've done that for
the last four years.
This has been a serious hustle.
Nothing has happened overnight.
We have made this our own thing.
Our intuition led us to
helping people with wellness.
JASON LOEBIG: So I just
want to give a little bit
broader perspective
over what Live Better is
and how we do it.
So Rachel gave a great intro.
We wear about 35
different hats, currently
working on making that 20.
But Live Better is a dynamic
health and wellness company,
and we just like to say that
we specialize in experiences.
So that could be something like
the wellness retreat we ran
in El Salvador-- we've
done a few of those--
all the way to big corporate
consulting projects.
We have written a Warm Up
for Work program for United
Airlines ramp operations
teams, all the people that
move your checked bags, helping
them stay healthier at work.
We've done things like
performance coaching
for executive clients.
We've done visualizations
for professional athletes
before races and
games, all the way down
to one-on-one
training for clients
as well as mindfulness
initiatives for children.
So we've been going into
some high risk school areas
to teach yoga and meditation
as behavioral modification.
And this long
journey has allowed
us to have several
different experiences, which
have been aided,
certainly, by Bret
and I both being Nike
trainers, most recently, Nike
run coaches.
We teach classes at
various boot camps,
which is a really great way
to get in front of a super fun
community.
And then we also
teach yoga, which
we've done on retreats, all
the way to doing things for fun
like rooftop yoga
during the summer.
Our big sort of purpose
at the beginning
was trying to marry
up our experience
we had in the corporate
world, which was not all bad.
We learned all the great
soft skills like showing up
on time for meetings and how to
host calls and conduct yourself
in a professional setting--
and help marry that with all
of these health experiences
that we've had,
because we know what
it's like to sit in that
seat for really long hours
at a time.
I know what it's like to
travel Monday through Thursday
with early flights, late
night returning home
with no food in the fridge.
And that's ultimately
what we wanted to do
was help our clients
and community
find strategies and ways to make
every day the best day ever,
no matter what it is you
liked doing for work.
BRET GORNIK: So we've
mentioned a few times
that we host wellness retreats.
On every retreat we
host, we hand out
a copy of our favorite book,
which is "The Alchemist,"
and I'd like to read a
quote from that book.
"'What is the world's greatest
lie?' the little boy asks.
The old man replies,
'It's this--
that at a certain
point in our lives,
we lose control of
what's happening to us,
and our lives become
controlled by fate.
That's the world's
greatest lie.'"
We're here today to
tell you that you are
in 100% control of your life.
You guys decided to show up.
You guys are here
right now by your will.
Every single decision that you
make every day is your choice.
It is extremely important
to become and really
believe in those decisions--
that we get to control our fate.
We decide where we want to take
our lives, what we want to do,
and how we want to get there.
You create your life.
JASON LOEBIG: So throughout
this journey that we've
had at Live Better,
we've sort of
settled on two really
foundational ideas
and steps we take
to build this life.
So step number one
is your purpose.
And while many of
you in this room
might be looking
up there saying,
I'm not really quite sure
I've found that yet, that's
totally OK.
And we'll touch on that again
later, but this is your why.
So if you haven't
found what that is,
or if you're not quite sure what
that deep, ultimate purpose is,
like, this is my calling.
I was born to do this.
I've been doing this
since I was five.
All I've ever done
is play the piano.
That's what I'm doing.
If you're like,
ah, that's not me,
these are the things that
keep you up at night.
The things that you wonder
about that pull at heartstrings.
If you've ever
volunteered for something,
that makes a big impact--
anything that keeps
you up at night.
They're also the thing-- that
also might be the thing that
wakes you up in the morning.
So I already mentioned I didn't
used to be a morning person.
Now getting out of
bed is a hell of a lot
easier when it's for something
that I really want to be doing.
Even on the days
where I'm tired,
I still can pop
out of bed knowing
that I'm going to make the
difference and the impact
that I set out to do.
And that is exactly the
second step and kind
of where Live Better
truly lives is self-care.
This is the fuel that you
use to pursue that purpose.
Without it, you are a
suboptimal version of yourself.
So if you give me 80% of
your energy and attention,
you are robbing me of 20%
of your ultimate gift.
If you add that up,
you walk in, you're
robbing your co-workers of
work that needs to be done.
You are robbing your
relationships of energy,
and you are not presenting
the best version of yourself.
This is Live Better's
true mission.
How do we help you
with your self-care,
and then encourage you
back towards your purpose?
Think about this, too--
that the more energy
you have, the more
energy you have to
pursue that purpose.
The larger that purpose
becomes, the more
it demands of your energy.
And round and round we go.
So if you're not quite
sure what your purpose is,
one good step to
find it might be
to fill up your energy
tank as high as it
can go so that you're ready
to take on those opportunities
when they come to you,
because if you come home
from a job or activities
that you really don't like,
and instead of going out
there and meeting people,
trying new things,
being positive,
which attracts
other people to you,
we don't allow anything
back towards us.
We sort of shut that off.
We go home.
We sleep.
We can't function
the way that we want.
We wake up tired the next day.
We go into something that we
don't like, and round and round
you go in the other direction.
And we create this
snowball effect.
So what's the
ultimate goal of this?
What happens when
we find our purpose,
we apply self-care to it?
We have the best day
ever every single day.
And everybody kind of
shakes that off at first.
They're like, oh, well,
that's just not possible.
I'm having a horrible day today.
Like, F you.
But this is not a Mr.
Positive nice guy attitude
at all-- quite the contrary.
This mindset is for the
days when shit hits the fan.
It's the days where everything
goes wrong, when you wake up
to your phone flashing.
You already have
way too many emails,
way too many text messages.
Something from
your personal life
bleeds into your work life.
You have a decision,
like Bret talked about,
every single day to either
victimize yourself, or get up,
figure it out, make the best
decision possible, and move on.
It's your decision to make
the next moment better
than the last moment, to
make the afternoon better
than the shitty
morning that you had.
If your morning and
your afternoon go south,
these are the PM
routines and the things
we can do for fun to kick us
out of that cycle of suffering.
And I think that's
really important to note,
because a lot of us feel
like life is happening to us.
Like, why do these horrible
things keep happening to me?
Why do people in my life keep
doing these things to me?
Why do I keep getting injured?
I tore my hamstring last
year, about a year ago,
off the bone in a
surfing accident,
and my entire life is my body.
If I can't use it, it's
really hard for me to work.
Everything I do for
fun is around moving,
so it kind of shook my identity
down to its core by saying,
everything you do for money
and everything you do for fun
has now taken a backseat.
And it could have been
very easy for me just
to sit on the couch, wallow
in it, complain about the fact
that I got hurt, and
I couldn't do this.
But instead I just did push-ups
and pull-ups instead of went
out for a run or doing squats.
I got surgery and
went back to teaching
four days later on crutches.
It's just my decision that
life happens around all of us,
and everything ends up being
just your reaction to it.
It's not happening to you.
You're the center of your own
universe but of nobody else's.
So it's understanding
that in context.
And if we think about,
what happens if we add up
all of these best days ever?
This is your best life ever.
It's an accumulation
of these days.
So it's worth it to consider,
moment to moment, day to day,
how do we have the best
day ever, because we're
stringing these together.
One thing I just want
to address really
quickly is that work-life
balance is made up.
So apart from maybe the world's
greatest lie that Bret read you
on the slide, the next
one might be the concept
of work-life balance itself.
It's also an extremely
dangerous contrast to make,
because if you
consider or associate
life, what you do after work,
with all the fun things,
then you are associating
work with the antithesis
of life, which would be death.
And you're all in here
still breathing, right?
So we must consider
what we do for work,
the majority of your life, as
part of that life equation.
If you are mailing it
in every day at work,
you are robbing your
co-workers of your talents,
and they're either
picking up your slack,
or you are underperforming
personally,
which then lets your team down.
The things that you carry from
your personal life outside of,
let's call work, back into
work affects your work,
and you certainly carry
your work home with you.
So we're going to talk about
a lot of strategies and ways
to get around some
of that, to be
able to perform better at work.
But if you're showing
up everyday at 9:01,
and you're leaving
everyday at 4:59--
if everybody does that,
it breeds a culture
of mediocrity and apathy.
Well, if no one else
cares, why should I care?
So then we talk about this
idea of work-life balance
like my life after
work is more important.
But that's not true.
What this very ill-worded
concept was trying to say
is that we should better
prioritize what we care about,
the impact we're making at work,
how you feel at work, because
then this blends
together into your day.
I think we can better determine
how we carry work into our home
life, and then how we
carry home life back
into work, if we consider how
to prioritize our entire day,
rather than making that
distinction between,
this is who I am and how I feel
at work, and this is who I am
and how I feel at home.
BRET GORNIK: So we
have a few principles
that we would like
to iterate and talk
about throughout our talk today.
Number one is discipline
equals freedom.
If you're unfamiliar with this,
it might seem counterintuitive
at first, that restricting
ourselves can actually
create freedom.
But this is a truth.
This is a fact.
If we think about it, we dive
into one of my favorite topics,
which is one of
the ways in which I
was able to leave behind what
I thought I was doing for work,
and now pursue my
dream every single day.
And this is a concept
of decision fatigue.
So our bodies fatigue when we
work out, when we go for a run.
We about physical fatigue,
but our minds fatigue as well.
Every single decision that
you make throughout the day
takes away some of
your mental energy.
So we think about
small decisions.
What socks are
you going to wear?
What are you going
to eat for lunch?
to do this weekend?
Then we think about
big decisions.
Am I ready to buy a condo?
Am I ready to ask this
woman to marry me?
Am I ready to go into this
meeting today at 3 o'clock,
my monthly meeting with my boss,
and tell him I need a raise?
So we break this down
on a granular level
by assigning points
to these decisions.
So let's say everybody
wakes up every single day
with 100 decision points--
picking out your socks,
picking out your breakfast,
one, two, five points.
It's nothing big.
That meeting with your boss--
that's going to take
40, 50, 60 points.
So just think about this.
Think about every single
day, every decision you make
is draining something.
This includes swiping
up through Instagram,
being on social media,
listening to phone calls,
watching TV in the
background while you're
trying to do something.
All of these take mental energy.
So let's go into an example.
You wake up in the morning.
You snooze your
alarm three times.
You pick up your phone--
emails, social media.
You scroll through.
You step out of bed.
You walk into your closet.
You like this shirt.
You like these pants,
these socks, these shoes.
You try them on.
You go on in the mirror.
Nah.
I'm going to go
take out this one.
You go switch your clothes.
You go out in the
mirror one more time.
You look at your phone.
You're like, oh, wow, it's
75 degrees in Chicago?
I'm wearing shorts.
You go back in.
You put on the shorts.
Already, we've
drained ourselves.
Then you realize that
you are late for work
because of all
that time it took.
So you rush to work.
You get in to work.
You sit down.
You haven't eaten breakfast.
You're hungry.
That starts to bleat.
It starts to bleat.
You start to get more and
more work put on your desk.
Now it's 11 o'clock.
Lunch is at 12:00.
What do we start doing?
Texting our friends.
Chatting with our colleagues.
Where should we eat?
What should we get?
Where should we go?
Where do you have a deal?
What's Uber Eats going on?
All of this different stuff.
And with that, we drain
from 11:00 until 11:35.
All of that time is
sucked out of your day
and your mental energy, deciding
on what to eat for lunch.
Then at 11:35, your
boss slams something
on your desk that's due at 1:00.
So all that time
you just wasted,
you now have to do this project.
You perform it suboptimally.
You hand it in at 1 o'clock.
You know that you didn't
do a good job on it.
Then you just go down, decide
to eat whatever's available.
Now it's 2 o'clock.
Your meeting's at
3 o'clock that you
wanted to ask for that raise.
You're a little fatigued.
You're a little tired.
So you say, you know what?
I'll push that
off to next month.
This compounds every single day.
You get home from work.
You're tired.
You're fatigued.
You throw on Netflix--
one episode, two, three,
eight, a full season.
You fell asleep
during one of the,
so you gotta watch the next one.
You order pizza.
You go to sleep.
You repeat.
A lot of us have had those days.
So let's take a step back.
Let's think about
how we can optimize
our day, every
single day, create
a cumulative effect on how we
can make ourselves our best
selves.
The night before, you
got your clothes ready.
You made your overnight oats.
You got your lunch ready.
You're ready to go.
You wake up in the morning.
You don't snooze your alarm.
You don't do that
in the morning.
You wake up, and you
stretch, and you breathe.
You put on your clothes.
You grab your gym bag.
You grab your food.
You walk out.
You have used zero points.
You get to work.
You're full.
Your energy's up.
You crush the morning.
That envelope slams at your
desk at 11:30, or that email.
You're ready to rock.
You crush it.
You hand it in at 12:30.
Now you have 30
minutes for yourself
to prepare for that
3 o'clock meeting.
You head into that meeting.
You smash it.
You say, I'm ready for a raise.
Your boss goes, of course,
you are always full of energy.
Everything you do helps
everybody in this office grow.
I was thinking about giving that
to you in this meeting as well.
You come home from work.
Instead of being tired,
you go right to the gym.
You work out.
Now you have more energy.
You just put in a lot
of work on your body,
so you decide to make
a healthy dinner.
After that healthy
dinner, instead
of wasting time watching
Netflix, you read a book.
That book teaches you something.
Now we compound
this, day after day.
Six months from now, instead
of reading that book,
you're thinking, I kind
of want to write a book.
Two years from now,
you wrote a book.
You laugh.
We did that.
We meal prepped.
We still do.
We get our clothes
ready the night before.
So now we're going to go over
ways in which we can do this.
So let's make
actionable decisions.
We can sit up here
and talk all day,
but if you guys don't
walk out of here
and fucking do anything,
it's not worth being here.
So we have a morning
and PM routine.
Everybody does, whether
you think about it or not.
Everybody can optimize it.
Everybody can do a
little bit better.
So let's break this down.
Every single thing we do
has to have a purpose.
So here's my example.
I wake up in the morning.
I go through four rounds
of a breathing technique
we're going to go
over here today,
so you know how to do it.
I hydrate, flush my body out.
I do my personal
care, brush my teeth,
make sure that I'm presentable,
so I can give talks like this.
I stretch and release so that
I'm ready to rock physically,
because physically,
like Jason mentioned,
is a very important part
of our day-to-day jobs.
Then I run through my day so
that I'm psychologically ready.
Notice no phone, no
wasted time, no points
used, because I do the same
thing every single day.
Then we get home from
work, and our PM routine
is just as important
as our morning routine.
So I shut off all
my electronics.
I drink a tea before bed
to get my body cooled down.
I read, I stretch,
and I decide what
I'm going to do the next day.
Each one of these routines is
no longer than 10 or 15 minutes.
We all have that time, but
it compounds, day after day
after day.
Then we start to assess,
how is this working?
What is working for me?
How can I create this
life to be even better?
Once we decide on these
routines and implement them
every single day, we can start
having the best day ever.
JASON LOEBIG: So before we get
to this breathing exercise,
Bret talked about
decision fatigue
being this point system.
So we arbitrarily
assigned 100 points to it.
Well, you're probably thinking
like, OK, well, right now,
maybe I only have 70 points.
I don't have 100.
I don't feel that great.
Well, there are two
things you can do.
Number one, you can increase
your points, or number two,
you can preserve them.
So we're going to talk about
two quick ways to increase them.
The first one would be
through your nutrition,
so the food we eat is the
foundation of the energy
that we provide our body.
Would you raise your
hand really quick
if you've ever eaten
pizza during a lunch
meeting or any type
of meeting and gone
back not feeling very good?
Yeah, literally, everyone.
Don't know why we still order
pizza for lunch meetings.
Don't eat the damn pizza.
You know that you're
not going to feel good
coming back from that meeting.
We have all this little
social stigma like, oh, you
didn't grab a slice.
Like, I'm watching you.
You have to be able to be
a leader in your office
and say, hey, maybe we should
order some healthier food
this time.
Or just simply
say, no, thank you.
I'm good.
I brought it in.
You make the decision
every single time
to put the fork in your mouth.
No one is force feeding you
that pizza, making you do it.
So we have to come up with a
better relationship with food.
One quick little point for
the parents in the room--
I would also suggest not
making the relationship
between good and bad
food subjective on taste.
So every time you
say, all right,
you can have your
dessert, but make
sure we finish all
of our veggies first,
or you can get to
this food, after you
make sure you eat
all this food, you're
creating the exact
same association
that work-life balance created
with a positive and negative.
You're associating the negative
food with the healthy portion
in order to get to the positive,
good-tasting food, which
is dessert.
And that gets ingrained in us.
Everyone's like, oh,
let's eat dessert first.
Life is short.
Well, maybe life is short,
because we eat dessert first.
[LAUGHTER]
So just think about that.
The second is exercise.
So if I asked you right
now if all of us got up,
and we went outside
for a run, and I
said, run as far as you possibly
can, you might get a mile.
You might get a couple miles.
If you're runners in the room,
just disregard this example.
We're going to come back to
talk about training for a goal,
like a marathon.
But if I trained you for six
months, and then I went out,
and I said, I want you
to run as far as you can,
you'd be able to
run a lot further.
So there is-- we
have the capacity
to increase the amount
of work we can do.
And endurance applies to a
lot more than just running.
It applies to our
emotional health as well.
So the second thing is,
how do we preserve points?
So sort of moving around this
holistic model of health,
we can manage our sleep.
Sleep is the most accessible,
best performance-enhancing drug
that you have access to.
If you don't get enough
sleep, you certainly feel it.
Most of the time, if
we do get enough sleep,
and we're not in
a deficit, we get
that pop out of bed feeling.
I'm ready to go.
We're all after that.
Almost none of us get that.
It's like a
penultimate sleep goal.
The second way would be
to manage your stress,
and that's something that we're
going to walk through today.
Bret mentioned a breathing
exercise that he does.
We're going to do that.
Just kind of quickly
on the graphic,
that is the stereotypical image
of what we consider meditation,
but it's not all monks sitting
in the mountains and mudras.
It's for graphic visualization.
Meditation is just simply
the scientific practice
of relaxing your
brain to preserve
some of those
resources, and it's
just rooted in a very
simple breathing exercise
that we're going to go through.
But I want you to think
about, instead of succumbing
to decision fatigue,
because we've
run out of all these points,
because we're stressed out,
because we have all
these things going on,
what if we could just take a
quick break, in the morning,
once during work, and
once in the evening?
And we could do that.
If we can do that, it allows us
to decrease some of the stress,
some of this overwhelm to
help the analytical side
of your brain
relax a little bit,
so we can start to
kick back up some
of the creative
side of your brain
that helps us
relax and have fun.
So we're not going to
metadata necessarily,
but we are going to do
this quick little breathing
exercise.
So I want you all just
to close your eyes.
You're going to sit
up nice and tall.
And I want you just
to start taking
deep breaths in
through your nose
and out through your mouth.
Each exhale you
take, I want it to be
audible enough so that your
neighbor to your left and right
can hear it.
I want the inhale you take to
be nice and quiet and calm.
As we start to do this,
I want you to add a count
to your breathing.
So when we start this count,
we'll go through four cycles.
You will inhale for
an easy count of four.
You will gently hold your
breath for a count of seven.
And then even more
gently, but audibly,
exhale for a count of eight.
These counts do not
need to be full seconds.
The better you get at this,
the more relaxed you get,
the longer these counts
might actually get.
So we're going to go through
four cycles all together.
I want you to inhale softly
in through your nose for four.
Hold for seven.
And then exhale out for eight.
Your neighbor should be
able to hear you exhale.
Inhale for four.
Hold for seven.
Exhale for eight.
Inhale for four.
Hold for seven.
Exhale for eight.
Do one more.
Inhale for four.
Hold for seven.
And audible exhale for eight.
And just gently open your eyes.
How many of you noticeably, from
the start to finish of that,
just feel like even a
little bit more calm?
So we start to let the
sympathetic side of our nervous
system, the side that we get
amped up for, the side that
our morning routine gets us
going for, our coffee gets us
going for-- first, second,
third, fourth cup--
that our workout
gets us going for.
We're always sympathetic, but
if we never turn that off,
we never give our body
a chance to relax.
That took under two minutes.
If you don't have enough time
in your day to close your eyes
or even just to step into
the bathroom for two minutes
to do that, then we need to
reprioritize a little bit,
because even something
as simple as that
can help relax your
brain down to remove
some of this chronic stress
that we're all underneath.
It can become very,
very important.
BRET GORNIK: And so we dive
into our second principle.
You are the average
of the five people
you spend the most time with.
This includes your colleagues,
your friends, your family,
and in today's day and
age, social media--
podcasts, who you're following,
who you're interacting with.
We spend a lot of time
on our mobile devices,
a lot of time at work, a lot of
time with family, a lot of time
with friends.
So for a moment, I want
you to just think about,
who are those
people in your life?
And are those people in your
life propelling you or holding
you back?
Are those the ones that
challenge you in the morning
to get up to a
workout, or are they
the ones that challenge you
to eat that slice of pizza
at lunch?
This is a very serious topic,
because we spend a lot of time
with a lot of different people.
And like we've
mentioned earlier,
you choose those people.
You choose to go to work.
You choose to go to
your family functions.
You choose to go out
with your friends.
You choose to go
to a workout class.
That is your choice.
And again, in
today's day and age,
we have the power
of social media
to choose whoever we
want to hang out with.
You can listen to podcasts.
You can read books.
You can follow amazing
people on social media,
or you can do the opposite.
And so with this, we
challenge everybody
to come up with their
board of advisors.
Run yourself like a
business, because you are.
You are your brand.
You are your life.
So we divide this
into three areas--
your health, your business,
and your recreation.
I want you to think about
right now three people
in each one of these spots that
you want to spend time with.
Who's going to motivate
you to work out?
Who wants to go
get an acai bowl?
Who would help
you start an idea?
Who thinks it's cool to
read books on the weekends?
Who would challenge
you on a weekend
instead of going out to
brunch to go rock climbing
or go on an adventurous trip?
These are the type of
people we need to spend
the majority of our time with.
We must realize that
you make the choice.
Now this isn't easy, because
a lot of us are sunk in.
You've had friends since you've
been growing up, which is fine.
But we need to just
realize that we can still
decide, through so many
different mediums now, that we
can create this epic
board of advisors.
JASON LOEBIG: I
think the toughest
thing about considering
some of these relationships
in this list are maybe the
people that don't actually
make it.
So a lot of us have had these
foundational relationships
for a very long
time, but just as we
can consider the
relationships in our life that
are essential to us, like
who might make up the three
people you trust with
your health the most,
it's also really,
really important
to evaluate the relationships
in your life, which
no longer serve you, that no
longer serve your purpose, that
no longer serve your self-care,
and that no longer serve where
you want to go in your future.
And these are the
hardest relationships
to consider, because
they're the ones
that you need to let go of.
And I don't mean
"let go of" like you
stop talking to your
drinking buddies
from college or the kids you
went to grade school with.
You can very much still love
them, still tell them that.
You just simply divert less of
your energy in their direction.
The other thing that's
really important to consider
is how flexible this list is.
So by recreation, we
mean what you do for fun.
The people that you
drank with in college,
you may no longer be
that close with as you
start to have children.
You hang out with whomever
your kids are hanging out with.
So the things that
you care about
are going to change based on
the condition of your life.
And they also certainly change
based on what you care about
and who you care about.
So constantly evaluating
these relationships,
and not in a shallow
way, but just in a way
that you know that who you
surround yourself with matters.
It really, really matters.
It has a huge effect.
You start caring about the same
things that they care about.
What car do they drive, and
what house do they live in?
Where do I want to go on trips?
What do I do for fun?
What are you doing
on the weekends?
Like, what are you doing later?
Those things seep into
your own lifestyle,
and if we don't
consider it, they
start to creep in a little bit.
So if you've got your
phone on you right now,
Bret and I are all about
taking action right away.
I'd like to introduce
just one quick activity.
We'd like you to show
your gratitude right now.
So if you have you phone,
please take it out.
This is the only
time you can do that.
Take it out, and text
somebody on that board
of advisors-- health,
business, recreation,
[INAUDIBLE] relationships.
My mom's sitting
in the front row.
So by default, text your mom,
if you're not quite sure.
I want you to explicitly
communicate to them
why you trust them
and why you want
them to hold you accountable.
That's the most important part.
This is not like, hey, I rely
on you for health information.
Like, thank you.
No, I'm relying on you
to keep me on track.
So first, please ask
them for permission.
Say, please.
Tell them to have the
best day ever, and then
definitely don't let them down.
That's the biggest part.
If you want a quick prompt,
I wrote one to Bret.
[INAUDIBLE] Live Better.
Talks at Google right now--
I'm evaluating my relationships.
You're on my health
team, and I want
you to keep me on track with
my training and nutrition.
Please let me know if
you're OK with that.
I appreciate you, and I want
to say thank you in advance.
So if you're not quite
sure what to write,
just swap out "Bret"
for someone else
that you trust with your health.
This is really
important, because we
have to consider why
we're doing this.
You're the easiest person
in the whole room to fool.
So creating some
outside accountability
is really, really important.
They're giving an
objective viewpoint.
When you spend that time
thinking about yourself,
you're victimizing
yourself a little bit.
Get out of your
own head by asking
somebody else for advice.
So while you're finishing up
sending this very nice text
message, I'm going
to let Bret explain
a little bit about
his story and how
Bret has used this concept
of board of advisors
and really considering
how the people in his life
have changed it.
BRET GORNIK: So this is
one of my favorite quotes.
"Set your life on fire.
Seek those who fan your flames."
So two health guys
coming up here talking--
we run every day.
We work out.
We teach.
We eat green juice.
I want to give you guys a
little anecdote about myself.
I was a savage in college.
I've drank more than
any of you in this room.
JASON LOEBIG: Combined.
BRET GORNIK: Combined.
Jason and I met under
those circumstances.
I was a bartender I would
chug bottles of Rumple Minze.
I would drink 20 beers before
I would go out to the bar.
I would proceed to take
my shirt off in the bar.
I didn't give a shit.
So I came from there.
That was me in college,
after I graduated.
I thought that's what life was.
I thought that my value
was being that guy,
being the MVP on spring break.
What does that even mean?
But it was when I
found my purpose,
I started to realize
that wasn't me.
Now I still go just as
hard, but in health.
So I surrounded myself with
those that fanned my flames--
my wife, Jason,
all of my friends
that are in this industry.
And it was hard.
I've had friends since
I was in high school
that I still consider
my best friends.
But I spend a lot
less time with them.
Why did I do that?
So I can be here.
It was not easy, and days
go by where it's tough.
But it's worth it when
you have a purpose.
And it means something when
those people reach out to you
for advice, when they
come to you, because you
are doing something
that seems so bizarre.
How do you make
money doing that?
Are you sure you want to leave?
You don't have a for 401(k).
Fuck that.
My purpose was found.
I found that.
You have to find that.
Then you have to
surround yourself
by the people that elevate
you, that bring you up
to another level, and
that's not going to be easy.
Nothing about
doing this is easy.
If it was easy,
everybody would do it.
There's nothing fun about easy.
So we want to offer you guys
ways in which we can do this
together.
JASON LOEBIG: So at Live Better,
this is exactly the community
that we're trying to build.
We run wellness retreats,
like the video that you saw,
which is kind of our
ultimate experience.
It's where you get to explore
things and ideas like this
and have conversations
with other people
that care about things
like this every single day.
And you get to do it in an
environment and setting that
doesn't distract you.
We've got touch
points in Chicago,
like a book club we
host once a month.
Lots of people in
this room are in it.
So we meet up.
We also get people
to Google Hangout
in from all over the place.
We run events during the summer
like rooftop yoga or dinners.
We train private clients
and do one-on-one coaching.
We try and provide as
many different outlets
to help you be accountable to
what it is you want to achieve.
We've got to wake up Wednesday--
newsletter that comes out
every Wednesday morning
that we try and make
motivational and a little bit
educational to get your week--
to give your week a
little bit of momentum.
We've got this podcast, where we
have interesting conversations
with people that are thinking
about life and business
a little bit different.
These are all ways in
which we found inspiration
from other people and are
paying that forward back
to our clients and community.
And that brings us to our
third principle, which
is adapted from a
Bill Gates quote,
and he talks about in a
decade, but I don't even
know what I'm doing next week.
So we've shrunk
it down a little.
It's that people overestimate
what they can do in a day
and underestimate what
they can do in a year.
Most of us enter every
day extremely stressed.
We're overwhelmed.
We're running from one
meeting to the next.
It's this text message,
this phone call.
We're on the phone, feeding
the kid in the back,
driving with our knee,
posting to our Instagram
at the same time.
We're depressed about
what happened yesterday.
We're anxious about what
might happen tomorrow,
and we're stressed about
what's happening right now.
We feel like life's getting
a little bit out of control.
It's like, ah, I was
too busy to workout.
No, you didn't prioritize
the time to work out.
You let something else happen.
What happens if we
reframe those emotions?
What happens if we are grateful
for what happened yesterday,
hopeful for what we
get to do tomorrow,
and just content to be where
our feet are right now?
You're in this room, taking
just an hour out of your day,
even if you take
nothing away, just
to listen to a different
viewpoint, somebody who's
doing something a little bit
different from their life
with what you might be
doing, and that is impactful.
And that is important.
So how do we create that
on a day-to-day basis?
It's by creating the
structure, framework,
and the people
surrounding us to apply
better goal-setting
strategies to execute that.
It's doing the right things,
being effective, and doing them
well, which is being efficient.
It's marrying those
two things together.
That is ultimately
where we start
to move to accumulate
all of these best days
ever into this longer life.
BRET GORNIK: So one
of the ways we do
this is through goal-setting.
And we break this goal-setting
down into four different areas.
Macro-- what is the goal?
So Jason and I have never
run a marathon in our lives,
and we're not just going to
run the Chicago marathon,
but we're going to race it.
We're going to do it
in under three hours.
We've decided on that goal.
We're going to start
with a health example,
and then we'll just give
you guys another one.
So we break that down into meso,
meso goals, smaller chunks.
If you've ever watched
me on my Instagram,
throw up these monthly goals.
That is the goal for the month.
So in August, we're going to run
40 miles a week, because that
will feed in to the macro goal.
Then we break it down
one step further, micro--
what are you doing
today for that meso goal
and that macro goal?
Today, we're going to
run four miles easy,
get our pace up, feel good.
All great.
You got your planners.
You got the stickers.
You got the notes.
You got all these
awesome ways to track it.
That's number four.
How do we track it?
So for this example,
we use the Nike app.
So we're able to run
with our app, track it.
There's a community
on there to get
people involved so that people
can see what you're doing.
You have to be motivated.
We look at each
others' all the time,
so tracking is super important.
Without tracking,
that cool sheet
of paper with the sticky
notes and all that on there
doesn't mean shit,
because you won't do it.
So let's think about
another example.
And again, we're not trying
to be shallow with this one,
but let's talk
about relationships.
Jason and I are both
happily married,
and one of the tools
that I use is--
another plug here--
Google Calendar to schedule time
for two things, three things.
Number one, time for
myself throughout my day,
which has a lot of different
things going on, to just think
about my relationships--
my wife, my friends,
and my family.
So once a week, 30 minutes
just to think about it--
no objective, no goal.
I'm going to do that.
It's on my calendar.
Number two is
every single month,
I write three gratitude
letters to people
that inspire me, friends,
family, people that I've never
met, just to share that up.
And then four is scheduling
events with my wife.
There's nothing
wrong with that--
dinners, fun nights out,
conversations about things
that aren't easy to talk about.
I have to do that, and it works.
So it's OK to schedule things
out in your relationships.
It's OK to do things like that.
It's great.
You are putting forth
effort to be your best self.
JASON LOEBIG: Our sort
of final ending thought--
if you've never heard the
man in the arena quote,
I'm going to read it for you.
If you have heard it
before, please just
consider how it might affect
you within the context
of the things that
we're talking about.
It's powerful enough to
take time to read it to you.
So, "It is not the
critic who counts,
not the man who points out
how the strong man stumbles,
or where the doer of deeds
could have done them better.
The credit belongs to the man
who is actually in the arena,
whose face is marred by
dust and sweat and blood,
who strives valiantly, who
errs, who comes up short again
and again, because there
is no effort without error
and shortcoming, but
who does actually
strive to do the
deeds, who knows
great enthusiasms, the great
devotions, who spends himself
in a worthy cause, who,
at best, knows in the end
the triumph of high achievement,
and who, at the worst,
if he fails, at least
fails while daring greatly
so that his place shall never
be with those cold and timid
souls, who neither know
victory nor defeat."
This quote encompasses
so many of the things
that we talked about--
just trying and doing
it, doing things
with enthusiasm and
a positive mindset.
The worthy cause
is your purpose.
You can think about having your
best day ever all you want.
You can map out your
New Year's resolutions.
perfect marathon PR time.
You can think about
that side hustle
you considered once or that trip
you want to take in the future,
but if you don't
actually do it--
Nike got this right
from the start.
Just do it.
If you don't actually do it, the
perfect plan you never follow
is worthless.
You're working out the
perfect rep scheme.
The perfect workout
is the worst one,
if you don't go out and do it.
And those cold and timid souls--
that's a little bit powerful--
sitting on the sidelines--
those are the people
critiquing you
that have never tried
to do what you've done.
Social media has been a
little bit bad about this.
We can just sit behind our
phone or computer and comment.
Somebody who else
is living their life
and trying to do something
with it, and that judgment
is creeping in and causing
a little self-doubt.
Fuck that.
You're the one in the arena.
You're the one putting
your foot forward.
It doesn't matter if you
fail, only that you try.
The strength that comes from
trying creates consistency.
We encourage you to get
out there and do it.
BRET GORNIK: And so from there,
we end with one key point
that Jason just mentioned.
None of this matters, if
you don't go do anything.
None of it matters if
Consistency is everything.
You must do it every single day.
You're tired?
You still got to
get your workout in.
You had a rough meeting?
You still got to
get your vibe up.
All of these things must
happen consistently,
because it creates momentum.
Like I mentioned with
that morning routine,
kind of joking about writing a
book, how do you think authors
write books?
They write.
You are a professional
in your life.
That is a different
mindset than an amateur.
The amateur does it.
They go for the run.
They jog.
No, we're professionals.
Every single one of you here
is a professional in your life.
And the only way to be the
best professional you can
is through consistency.
It creates a positive
snowball effect.
You roll that ball down the
hill, it gains momentum.
You start bringing people in.
You start highlighting things.
You start going to
events like this.
You make yourself
your best self.
JASON LOEBIG: I think the
true purpose of self-care
and why we kind
of start with that
is what you get to
do with it after.
It's not-- the end game
is not nice-looking abs
and a slim waistline.
You've been working
on losing weight.
Great.
You lost weight.
Now what?
What are you going to do?
Is this a lighter, happier,
stronger human being?
You focused on
running this race.
Great.
You finish.
Now what?
This is what self-care is.
It's taking that and
applying all the things
that you learned from
doing it and that you
gained from doing
it, and it's just
helping the people around you.
You're not quite sure
what your purpose is yet.
How about starting
exactly where you're
at with what you're
capable of doing
to help the person sitting
next to you, to help somebody
in your community?
I don't care if
it's volunteering
10 minutes of your time,
$10 of your income.
What you do with your energy--
that's what matters.
That's where we turn
self-care into purpose.
That is the next step.
There's another
great Rumi quote that
says, "Live life
as if everything
is rigged in your favor."
And it ties back
to "The Alchemist,"
that the whole world
is conspiring to help
you do what you need to do.
And then when shit
hits the fan, that's
why we have all
these strategies.
When you get injured mid-racing
cycle, when you have something
go horribly wrong in
your personal life amidst
the best stretch of
your professional life,
how do you handle that?
Without energy, no chance.
That's where this
becomes super important.
It's your responsibility
to show up
like a professional
with your tank full.
You have the opportunity
to make an impact
on the world on your own terms.
And if you let
it, the world will
dictate what that is, instead
of the other way around.
This is how we get to live
our best life every single day
and what it means to have the
best day ever every single day.
BRET GORNIK: So we have
one final activity.
Everybody, stand up.
So we're going to
try to go viral.
I brought my selfie
stick, so we're
going to do a
little video, where
I'm going to cue everybody to
say, "Have the best day ever."
And I'm not just
going to say it.
Zach, I need you to yell it.
Everybody here, you
have to yell it.
You guys ready?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
BRET GORNIK: All right,
we're going to do that again.
Are you guys ready?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
BRET GORNIK: All right.
So I'm going to say, 1, 2,
3, and then everybody says,
have the best day ever.
All right?
JASON LOEBIG: [LAUGHING]
BRET GORNIK: Are we live?
JASON LOEBIG: Make
sure it's recording.
BRET GORNIK: Oh, we're live.
JASON LOEBIG: Yeah, we're on.
We're in it.
BRET GORNIK: You guys good?
JASON LOEBIG:
Yeah, you count it.
BRET GORNIK: I'm
going to be going--
like, I want screams
and high fives
and jumping jacks, hugs,
kisses, whatever you want to do.
All right, are we ready?
Are we hyped?
Let's go.
Come on.
Let's get it going.
Let's go.
All right.
So it's going to be 1, 2, 3,
and then we're going to say,
all right.
Ready?
JASON LOEBIG:
That's a good swing.
BRET GORNIK: One, two, three.
ALL: Have the best day ever.
[APPLAUSE]
BRET GORNIK: Let's go!
Let's go!
Talks at Google, what up?
JASON LOEBIG: We hope that--
we hope that everybody
can live better.
We thank you guys very,
very much for coming.
[APPLAUSE]